-You know,
I've thought it over,
and I've got to hand it
to you guys,
this trip is actually a really
great idea.
-This is surprising,
you're usually a lot more
petulant when we don't
go along with your schemes.
-Stratagems,
and I've grown up a lot, Terry.
-Uh, you do know
there's no phone reception
at the lake house?
-No!
How am I gonna catch Pokémon?
It doesn't matter.
It's a community even weekend.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Andy Samberg.
Hello, old friend.
-Hi, Seth.
-You, um,
you're fighting a cold and
that's how pretty much
how I knew you for the first
seven years of our friendship
was fighting a cold.
I felt like, since you moved to
California you got less sick all
the time.
But is this just the norm?
-We went on a family trip
and then saw my family.
And they got everyone sick.
[ Laughter ]
-Gotcha.
-So, like, I had moved past it
as a member of my family
but then I guess my family gets
everyone sick.
-Yeah, well that's --
it's nice to know that you
point fingers at your family
as well as my dog.
-My sister's kids.
-Gotcha.
-Boned this segment,
they boned this segment.
-Hey, I want you to know,
I mean,
this is still on the desk
since you did it.
Well, you did a famous
mommy character.
And we have you on the desk.
And it's really nice
because we also have
we have the character
I'm asked about the most,
Stefon and the one that I've
never been asked about once.
-Right.
And so you want to get
something sort of
in the middle next?
Probably.
-Yeah, like something
right in the middle.
-As far as popular characters.
You wrote me this summer,
basically, to thank me
for the holiday card
that we sent you,
which is a weird time
to get that feedback
because, of course,
it was a full six months
after you received it.
-Yeah. What happened was we put
all of our mail in a bag
because of COVID, and then,
you know, to let it burn off
because we knew a lot
about the virus at that time.
And then we forgot
about the mail. [ Laughs ]
So, yeah, about a month ago
I read about 75 holiday cards
and started reaching out
to people.
But I really liked
your holiday card this year.
You went out of your way
to say
Frisbee didn't make
the cut this year.
-Yeah, Frisbee was not
on the holiday card.
-Because.
Same time, count of three,
one, two, three.
-Frisbee's horrible.
-Ugly piece of [Bleep]
rat dog, piece of [Bleep]
-[ Laughs ]
What did you say, because there
is another kid to put on there.
-I do want to point out,
I think we've talked about
this on the show,
two years ago
when Frisbee was on
the holiday card,
you sent it back to us.
-Right.
-Which is the only time
in my life
we've received
a holiday card back.
You didn't even want it
in your home.
-[ Laughs ]
It was stinking up the joint.
Hey, speaking of which,
do I need to send you
back the Fauci lab coat?
Because I don't want
an assignment for this.
-You can keep it,
because I feel like
you're probably
going to be asked to do it
at like events
like corporate events.
-It's for sure going on
my best of.
-Your best of --
Your best of "Late Night."
-Yeah. When did "SNL" stop
doing "best of's"?
-Yeah, I guess maybe when
the DVD industry dried up.
-Right.
Anyway, I'm going to take
my temperature real quick.
Let's see what we've got.
I think that's for butt holes.
-99.3 doing okay.
Little hot, might have been
the lab coat
-That's a nice -- you' know I've
never had as good of a segue,
but you're running
a 99 temperature.
-That was planned.
Buddy, congrats.
This is eight seasons,
very incredible,
especially because
this show famously canceled
and then brought back.
At what point did it go from
being a show that you were on?
That was a very funny
and a very good show
to something that I believe
became really special to people,
was that during the time
where people thought
it might be gone forever?
-I feel like that was when it
sort of had a moment
of everyone talking about it,
at least,
Like when it first
came out,
it was well received
and it was great.
But then, when it got canceled,
it was sort of part
of the, like, a press train
about something else,
which is like,
hey, fans can save shows.
Isn't that interesting?
And then we were the example
that was getting news so much
so it was kind of like
culturally kind of
a little moment.
I've always said it was a really
slow news day, but I'll take it.
You know,
I remember we were flying
to New York for the up-fronts
and everyone at the airport
was like,
"Hey, congrats on the show
getting picked up."
And I was like, since when
do people follow, like,
the inner workings of,
you know, shows?
But anyway,
I think we were lucky
that it didn't
get fully canceled.
And we have mostly you
to thank Seth, obviously.
-Thank you, buddy. Thank you for
giving me the credit I'm due.
When?
How did you hold up?
You don't have any water.
-It's gone now. And it's a shame
because I sound like [Bleep]
-When how did you hold up both
physically and emotionally
during the last season?
-It was hard.
I mean, it was hard shooting
A because the COVID protocols
are so strict
and, you know,
there's no writer on set.
There's not people
throwing around a lot of ideas.
It's a lot of like masks on
and the action take them off
and then you do
and you put them back on.
So, you know, that was hard.
But just as
it got towards the end,
it got really emotionally rough
because we all realized
it was truly ending.
And we all love each other.
And I've been spending all that
time together for eight years.
And yeah, there was a lot
of crying like the wrong times.
There's scenes where you could
argue, like you should cry.
And then there's other stuff
where it's like I just fell out.
And I'd be like, I just realized
the last time
Terry is going to say
he loves yoghurt.
-How did it compare
to leaving "SNL"?
We had a similar amount
of years on.
-Yeah. It's interesting
leaving "SNL."
It's interesting.
This is terrible television.
I tried to text you and
Shoemaker and you were like,
"He's fine."
if I had bailed, right?
-Yeah.
-I never would've
heard the end of it.
-Right. You had to tough it out.
And I feel like people at home
are watching right now
and they're appreciating
this effort.
-I feel like they're probably
changing the channel.
Like this is unlistenable.
This dude is sick
and I don't want
to experience that with him.
-I mean, I think everybody is
probably super mad
at your, what are they,
nieces and nephews?
-Yeah, one niece, one nephew.
-Okay, one of each.
-Yeah. They got my kids sick.
Then she got me sick.
So I'm kind of mad at her,
too, my kid.
-No, this, this is good TV.
-[ Laughs ]
What else is going on
in the news?
So tired.
-Should we let --
-Temp check.
-We'll get one last temp check
and then let you go.
Let's see how hot
this segment is.
-Oh, yeah, it's back up to 100.
-[ Laughs ]
The eighth and final season of
"Brooklyn 99,"
premieres is tomorrow night
at 8. [ Laughs ]